genius by listeners this podcast is
brought to you by raycon my friends if
you're looking for high quality things
at the best price when it comes to
wireless earbuds you are in luck we are
talking about raycon wireless earbuds my
friends Ray Conn's mission is to prove
that you shouldn't have to pay an arm
and a leg for Quality sound and
essential smart Tech listening features
three customizable sound profiles earbud
tap functions noise isolation and so
much more go to buybraycon.com brand new
day to get 15 off your recon order
that's by raycon.com brain to score 15
off by raycon.com brain genius brain
listeners you already know I mentioned
this quite a while ago but pre-orders
will be starting soon we will let you
know make sure that you follow me on
Instagram follow secret society and we
will let you know when the genius plays
secret society anime inspired shirts are
dropping for pre-orders the pre-orders
will be roughly about for two weeks
First People Order uh get their shirts
first so just keep that on your
calendars and get ready I'll let you
know when it's going to happen when
pre-orders start just follow me on David
So comedy and also follow
scrt-s-o-c-i-e-t-y secret society on
Instagram and sign up for the emails as
well
put the blame on me and they were saying
that
like it was my fault and that it was my
attitude and my pride
using that word yeah right because they
were even you know what's worse you want
to hear this one they were like God told
me that you have to do this that if you
do this video you would bless you I'd be
like dude that's crazy in five four
three two one what's up everybody
welcome to another episode of The Genius
brain podcast uh for those of you who
are first time listeners and those of
you who aren't uh you probably heard me
say this a million times welcome to
chaos
genius praying is not a podcast about
intellectual thought it's a the exact
opposite it's just you know the fly on
the wall and you're listening to people
listening to our brain farts exactly
it's just coming out of our mouths yes
um I do want to address something real
quick
um it's something that has been on my
heart and I wanted to say this to the
people who wrote these comments when I
was doing the whole when I you know we
were talking about the whole thing that
happened with the Dalai Lama and from
the bottom of my heart I just want to
say this like straight up [__] you like
God damn I was like um
all right
let me explain this thought I didn't see
that coming
the audacity all right
this is the funny thing about the
internet
this is the thing about the internet
that irritates the [__] out of me we
don't know what's true or not right
before I did a Dalai Lama podcast right
three days I read up about this stuff I
was trying to read about the religion it
was so confusing it was stressing me the
[__] out right
so the podcast comes out obviously
you know after more information comes
out right yeah but I sat on it for about
a week like six seven days and this is
all the information that was coming out
the only information that was coming out
was that when he stuck out his tongue
right the reason behind that that was
only online the nothing else came out
was that it happens in Tibet because
it's it's something that happened when
they had like the despotic ruler who had
a black tongue because he was evil so in
order for people to show that he isn't
reincarnated in them they would stick
out their tongue I don't have a black
tongue right that was the only reason
that was given out there was a vice
article that came out that said that old
people in Tibet like grandmas and
grandpas will be like stick out your
tongue and they want it's the literal
translation isn't suck my tongue it's
eat my tongue right and if Dalai Lama
can't speak English very well so it came
out really weird right right so
here's what I [__] hate about some
people
you didn't know either
you did it no either you saw the vice
article after the fact waited two days
later and then you said David I can't
believe you didn't know this do your
research
found out
[Laughter]
I'm sorry that's the most [__]
animated I've ever seen you bro
[Laughter]
so [__] you
do you have any idea how much of a
psychopath you have to be to just find
out information and then shave somebody
else for not knowing for something you
found out
bro in the video I put all these like
references everything from like all
these different places websites I was
reading about it for three [__] days
right right I was Googling things saying
like what does this tongue thing mean is
there another meaning for it the only
thing that popped up was the explanation
of the despotic king that's it right and
even when it first came out people were
defending him saying it was in reference
to the king nobody not a single [__]
article not a single comment on YouTube
explained that the translation was wrong
and he was saying eat my tongue right
and this is what oh nobody said it until
the vice article and then people start
copying pasting the vice article writing
comments to me this is what it actually
means I'm from Tibet you're copying
tasting the vice article you are not
from Tibet
and then your avatar is like Buddha
thank you
I hate it when people do that and
they're like you can do better be better
you know what can be better when you
suck my nuts from the backside
I did my research to the best of my
ability yeah okay I did everything that
I could to the best of my [__]
ability when you just find out
information you say hey David this Vice
article came out we just found this out
this is what it actually is don't say I
knew it the whole time and let me give
you even more back reference you [__]
all right I have a friend it's not his
real name but it's a nickname that we
call we call him pooj
yeah
pusha's parents are [__] Tibetan
Buddhists right right which I never
understood because I always thought
Buddhist people were Chinese but
apparently like Buddhism started like in
India yeah I didn't know this right
which was always confusing me never put
two and two together so you know we're
joking around right I hit a pooj I'm
like so what's up with your parents the
freaks or what you know and he's
laughing right and then I asked him I
was like is that like some like like
Buddhist [__] that they do he goes nah
my parents think that he's [__] weird
yeah so his parents thought so you know
I'm I'm getting all these I was like
okay so it's not this black and white
thing right or it's everybody in Tibet
and India know that this is [__]
normal I even put in a reference where
there was
um a child's right activist group in
Delhi that was like we know about the
tongue thing that's weird so
I did my research nobody [__] knew
about that type of stuff right yeah I
understand right here's some people they
came in like well you know he's our
religious leader listen we've talked
about multiple times on this podcast
about Christian leaders who we shat onto
none of you ever defended them oh my God
I I talked so much [__] about Christian
people for the last three years dude
not one person said hey you don't talk
about religion that way no one [__]
person [__] on Phil Wickham
is like a rat face ugly dude Chris
Tomlin sure yeah David Crowder is
homeless you know nobody said anything
yeah you know what I'm saying
like the like this is what I just was so
I just wanted to get that off my chest I
understand if it is your religion it's a
very sensitive sore spot all right but
so is sexually assaulting a child and
like I said I don't know if that's the
case or not but from my perspective
that's what it looked like from my
research from what I found it was just
things just didn't [__] add up and it
doesn't and it still doesn't make sense
to me a little bit if you guys just want
to tap into like just step out of
yourself for a second
why did it take like a week and a half
for them to be like oh the translation's
wrong um
so the here's the other thing that I
want to bring up that somebody else
brought up in a comment and this person
was going off on me they're like what
are you a CCP cuck I was like what a
career how dare you
first of all I'm Korean you [__] the
hell you talking about yeah and so
they're saying that this possibly could
be like an attack from the CCP where
because this didn't happen recently yeah
well so why is this resurfacing now
right so they're saying they're using
this as propaganda to kind of like
destabilize them and kind of [__] with
them a little bit which also kind of
makes sense too so this thing was just a
lot bigger than what you know how the
situation there's two Dalai llamas right
there's two yeah there can't be that
doesn't make anything so the Dalai Lama
we know you know who's world famous
ISO yeah yeah and then there's a Dalai
Lama that's approved by the CCP
of course
in China so the CCP is trying to promote
this Dalai Lama and say no this is your
guy not that guy that the world Alibaba
Dalai Lama dude
the audacity wow that's a good one
it's Alibaba ass Dalai Lama which this
now makes more sense yeah now now it
makes I guess why they would they would
do [__] like this right yeah how the
[__] was I supposed to know you cookies
CCP cook yeah I'm from the Communist
party please
get the [__] out of here what are you
talking about hey man new information
comes out we get a chance to [__]
speak about it you know
so once again from the bottom of my
heart
[__] you [__] you very much yeah and I'm
also very sorry like I didn't know
hahaha
all right uh Korean to the end yeah it's
the both like extremes you it's true
though you feel both of them you [__]
the most secular be so [__] sorry
yeah I'm so [__] sorry I found out
after you guys found out all right
Jesus none of you were saying that in
the beginning of the video but two days
later suddenly you have all this
information yeah I read it too
everybody's got a reaction man
I'm so sorry okay I'm so sorry
Jesus Christ man well it's just an
unfortunate video but then it's like you
know at the same time like I can see why
they're pissed yeah because you can
realize and whatever right but guess
what millions of people around the world
the story has already ended yeah and
they're not gonna hear you so I'm
correcting it right now yeah it could be
a CCP attack because they're trying to
promote the Alibaba Dalai Lama
all right the [__] Jack mod Dalai
Lama I get it okay and that's a very big
possibility we don't know what the [__]
is happening in this world I don't get
anything at all yeah so when they
brought that up I was like oh this is
very interesting you know you think that
I was gonna sit there and be like no not
real I don't know anything I'm open to
new ideas all the time yeah just type it
and I and I pin somebody's comment
because they were very kind they were
like hey I'm from Tibet and I wanted to
let you know which that person most
likely wasn't from Tibet they just
wanted to say that so they could sound
like they're smart because once again
they copied and pasted the device
welcome to the internet right yeah I'm
from Tibet as a black person you know
that was the version of that yeah maybe
you are from Tibet I don't know most
likely you're not and I feel like you're
lying but you said it very kindly so I
pinned it and I said this is very
important
and still people were calling me a CCP
cuck which is hilarious I'm not a
Chinese yeah
there if if that was the if that was the
case we wouldn't have [__] on Mulan so
bad exactly we would have been like this
great go back and listen to the Mulan
review we totally [__] on it and expose
it for being like CCP propaganda I'm a
Timeless thing David so is a communist
yeah just because you look like him Jung
yeah you think I'm you think I'm a
number one Economist you're crazy that's
the funniest thing about that is that
how you were imitating Kim Jong ill with
Kim jong-ilah he dies and then his son
comes out of the word works we see him
for the first time
yeah
I know great
dude I was so mad when Kim Jong-il died
because like I was like dude my
character
[Laughter]
hey David
David life you should be worrying about
somebody that that is like the most
extreme idea of being like
people are so [__] funny man I just I
just I've been holding that in for the
longest time and I'm so glad I got to
say it man dude [__] um I told the
story on the podcast with Tim I wanted
to tell you this [__] like you know
because when when you and I when you
first saw me get crossfaded and I was
like in Another Universe
I've gotten like comments where people
tell me like bro that's not what happens
when you're on weed I'm like I know
dummy I don't know what the [__] that
was it was a whole [__] dropper of
Delta eight right and three glasses of
vodka it was
nuts yeah you know what I mean I
literally thought I died I literally
told this man hey Ed I figured it out
I've been dead yeah you know you're like
this is it this is how I die
if I could [__] with you if I was a
worse man I would have been like you
should call your mom tell her goodbye I
literally like blasted out of my body
yeah floating in the air and I was like
I did this whole time and I just like I
figured out the Matrix yeah I was like I
figured it out I've been dead and this
whole time
I just didn't know I'm free so I thought
I had it all figured out yeah
so I was with Robin and I got [__]
high as [__]
and then I went to uh a pharmacy store
after I left this house to get
to get allergy medicine because I was
just [__] you know allergy season's
crazy right now like I've been sneezing
like a [__] I haven't been able
to sleep so I I want to get some [__]
out of Pharmacy
every now and then you'll meet like a
very weird fan right most people very
kind but there's always somebody that
comes out that's very odd and I this is
the thing I dread the [__] most I
post videos of me training because it
motivates people to work out and it
motivates me to work out yeah right it's
your accountability yes I've seen people
lose weight through it I've seen people
change their lives through it and it's
something that I feed off of because it
keeps me going it helps me stay in check
because I want to be about the [__] that
I say about I want to show people that
I'm improving I'm like one of the few
people out there that show them boxing
from day one where they couldn't throw a
punch all the way till now everybody has
seen the [__] Journey yeah and I
don't care right
um that being said there's always going
to be somebody that tries to throw
punches at me what so this [__]
not even that way he comes in right this
guy weird as [__]
tell the story on Tim's possible I'm
gonna get into more detail about this
one so there's a pharmacy close to my
house that I that I go to right
going in
this [__] come say yo what's up
Dave it's like oh man I see you got
[__] hands and he's like I don't know
if he's drunk or weird he's like oh
it Jabs at my face and she's at the
pharmacy at the pharmacy because he
recognizes me right he goes I see you
got moves I ah right by the way I'm high
I don't know what the [__] going on
right he's like oh yeah like oh you know
doing all this [__] like Shadow Boxing
in front of my face
everything he's throwing at me is
delayed
right so this dude I'm not doing
anything I'm just like this staring at
him because I'm high yeah right but I
think he took that as like me being
irritated at him right
so he's thinking that I'm like too cool
for school because I'm not really saying
much right whatever so he turns around
he turns away and he comes back and does
this right and I'm staring dead in his
face and I'm not I didn't Flinch at all
he goes oh I see man you about the life
all right that's cool man I respect that
and he walks away right but I was so
high he walked away and then three
seconds later I went oh
congratulations
[__] process it
so this little thought I had I was like
a stone cold dealer I was high as a
[__] yeah all right I see you
and you got a heart okay he walks away
just it's like I'm so [__] high dude
I don't know why I meet some of the
weirdest people like let me tell you
something like just because you see me
like train here and there
you shouldn't walk up to somebody just
start throwing punches at their face
yeah it's weird it's just socially
awkward yeah I don't understand what he
was thinking were we supposed to box
each other in the middle of a Walgreens
like what are we gonna do here yeah I
don't know like weird I think like I
said
I'm learning this but a lot of people
out there man you got to manage your
expectations like what are you thinking
like is going to happen if you go up to
someone and start throwing Jabs like
Shadow Boxing with them right what's
gonna happen like what if you actually
hit me that would have hurt yeah with
your Delayed Reaction yeah you would
have hit me and I would have just been
Stone Cold face and you would have
walked away and I would have went
I I think because I speak so like
passionately and emphatically yeah
people think that I'm ready to fight 24
7.
no no there's a reason why I have a
mouth on me yeah you know what I mean
like I'm not a [__] fighter yeah if
it comes down then I have to Baby You're
a [__] talker I talk [__] yeah yeah I
mean it's what I do it's my [__] crap
baby yeah you know
uh listen if somebody ever came out to
me in public right and they were like
I'm gonna [__] you up I'm not gonna
fight them yeah most like listen I
understand I'll be telling stories here
and I'm like look I wish a [__]
would I have to say that yeah
because I can't openly just be like yeah
anybody could just [__] me yes please
don't yeah please don't I'm not gonna
like okay
realistically speaking yeah everybody
says the same thing when they see me
you're a lot bigger than I thought
everyone expects you to be like five six
yeah
it was the angle of your Vlog video you
know
you don't hold it because they wanted
people to see my hat design yeah because
if it's straight on you only see the
bill yeah so I wanted people to see the
Hat let me see that right I remember
when I did that like hey uh it was um
what's her [__] face
Arden Cho she was like it was like oh
that's really smart when you angle it
makes your face look skinnier I was like
it does
because I didn't know that's what girls
do when they take selfies because it
makes their face slender yeah because I
wanted people to see my hat yeah that
was it so I didn't know that that was a
[__] thing but it was like a beauty
angle type of thing apparently and then
there was a point where people were
using a ring light hey uh maybe dudes
were doing that a lot yes the ring light
cam yeah really [__] weird and you
see like the little halos in their
[__] eyes like little anime
characters and [__] it makes your skin
look nice hey hey speaking of Arden Cho
I I I've been wanting to say this for
the longest time and I refrain from this
because I'm a good person Jesus Christ
her Netflix show was so bad I didn't see
it it got canceled yeah so I didn't say
anything because
we'll talk about it later because you
haven't seen it yeah I've watched three
episodes and it was the longest longest
three hours of my [__] life okay so
you want me to watch three episodes I
want you to watch I want to see if you
can even get through three episodes it
is hilariously terrible okay
you know a part of me always wanted to
watch bad content to review it on
purpose like let's go like send us bad
movies to review so we can make fun of
it I always want to do that too we could
do the first one I forgot what it her
her show was called it was like called I
don't know Lawless in Chicago or
something I have no clue I don't know
like you know shout out to Arden Cho she
made her bag I appreciate it that's
[__] dope
oh it was so bad
one of the worst series I've ever seen
in my life what are the worst
representations for women I've ever seen
in my life really it made well that was
the show with the caricature gag dude
yes right
stereotype gay dude it the oh
shout outs to you I appreciate but look
now that the show's canceled I could say
this if it was still going I would never
say it because I'm not trying to [__] up
her bag yeah and I want her to make her
money be successful all good I would
just be talking [__] about it in private
you know I would never let it go out in
public but now that is canceled what
Jesus
dude I was always thinking to maybe I
want to review like a bad Christian
movie like uh God's Not Dead have you
heard of that
I I just want to watch a bad movie to
just talk about it for a second oh we
could do bad movie reviews for sure
that'd be great we'll do one after beat
next time we'll do beef and we'll do a
bad movie review yeah um throw it in the
comments what's some like a terrible
movie for us terrible movies so uh
obviously I'm surfing through the
internet and
this world that we live in is so [__]
weird like celebrity boxing has gotten
so out of hand like they literally
started whole promotions where it's only
like YouTube like streamers circus dude
it's a new circus and I gotta tell you
with some of the most UN entertaining
things I've ever seen in my life like
when you watch real boxers go it's
[__] crazy yeah it's it's kind of
nuts how fast they are yeah their
instincts and it's it's a sight to
behold and then you see influencer
boxing which I actually the the last one
that they did
um it was this guy I really like it was
the Epic Meal Time guy Harley yeah yeah
he boxed in it too but it was all for
charity all the money went to charity
which I think that's kind of that's a
lot better I I appreciate that a lot
even that's what it used to be celebrity
boxing used to be charity fights yeah
that's why Lamar Odom [__] Nick Carter
or something
because it was a freak Show I was the
craziest [__] fight I've ever seen in
my life
the car's not the one that passed away
I think they both passed away Jesse
McCartney No Aaron Carter Aaron Carter
Aaron Carter was that one of them passed
away everyone but one of them passed
away right yeah it was the Backstreet
Boys younger brother yes yes yes yeah
yeah so he he passed away he wasn't the
one that he was the one that was boxing
yes I think he boxed oh that's so sad
but hey it was for charity it was for
charity right that's what it used to be
but now it's like they're realizing wait
there's a lot of there's a lot of money
in this yeah um but because of that you
know Jake Paul lost his last match with
the real boxer and it wasn't even close
it was like a split decision but Jake
Paul just got his ass pieced up it was
it was it was not a close [__] fight
at all and by the way I say this because
I was actually rooting for Jake Paul I
was pissed I was like what the [__] is
this because I got kind of caught into
the hype like the first thing that I was
saying in the beginning was Jake Paul's
not a real boxer yet yeah uh he has a
long way to go and you know like you
kind of sucked in because you know he
fought Anderson Silva and stuff I'm like
maybe he's really dope then he fights
Tommy Fury who isn't that great himself
because he's a beginner yeah he got
peace the [__] up I was like oh [__]
he's not that great and now he's
fighting Nate Diaz right the Stockton
Bad Boy right right
um
and I love Nate Diaz right but that
[__] got CTE like nothing else
yeah his speech has been slurred since
the first season of The Ultimate Fighter
it's so bad now yeah I don't know what
hey [__] yeah I [__] yeah I
don't give a flaming yeah
I'm like what is he saying that's like
it's like all there yeah
so I guess they were out in New Orleans
and that that's where this uh influencer
boxing thing was going down and then uh
Nate Diaz there's video of him choking
out somebody who looks like it could be
Logan Paul yeah
that's his whole thing right that he's a
Logan Paul look-alike that's his claim
to fame it's literally the saddest thing
I've ever heard in my life
but they're all New Orleans and you see
this video right if you guys haven't
seen this video you see Nate Diaz and
this Logan Paul look-alike which at
first it was said that it was Logan Paul
because he he looks like a crackhead
version and they're like the same height
same build everything yeah comes up
hands up but he's walking towards Navy
yeah at him and then next thing you know
you see him in a front choke and he
[__] chokes him out he needs him real
quick chokes him out and then he drops
him and he just walks away right which
is actually very kind yeah he didn't
throw any fish he just he put him to
sleep put him to sleep and he fell over
and he cracked the back of his head so
he was bleeding a little bit he's
perfectly fine
um
natives have got arrested ten thousand
dollar bill
and like the comments are very
interesting most people I say 90 of the
cop 99 of the comments are like he
shouldn't be at fault for this yeah and
the one percent that believes that he
should be I don't think you understand
what this means so the the argument
behind that is that well clearly he was
showing that he wasn't aggressive
because he put his hands up that only
applies if you're backing oh away yeah
you can't put your hands up and progress
forward yeah that's deceptive exactly
this man is a trained fighter also too
it's on video yeah like so I guess
people in their mind think like oh this
is this is like damning proof that he
didn't want to fight because his hands
were up you know what also means that
your hands are up you want to fight yeah
what are you trying to give him a hug
yeah so why are you moving forward move
that way yeah don't do this and walk
forward you know what that means in the
hood
I don't want to fight I'm lying and I'm
going to beat the [__] out of you right
and so he did the great the graceful
thing of choking him out yeah didn't
[__] throw in punches or blows he
just choked him out knocked him out he
moved on the worst thing that happened
was that he hit his head and I'm pretty
sure that wasn't his intention to make
his head smack the ground yeah his real
intention was to put him to sleep which
he did why are you approaching a [__]
MMA fighter yeah like a very well-known
MMA fighter that's a legend like Nate
Diaz that way yeah you know who's known
not to give a [__] about him how many
fights under his belt you know you can
include the losses but still that's how
many times did he get in the [__]
octagon
over 40 times right yeah this guy's a
very interesting Dude too it's like is
the only thing you're known for is for
looking like Logan Paul and you're I
read somewhere where he's actually been
training in combat
sports like part of his social media is
where he's been doing some MMA training
so it'd be like I don't know that might
be [__] because she [__] just pops
up on your feet and somebody says
something but it was Jake Shields he I
mean Jake Shields says crazy [__] I
don't even follow him he just comes up
on my feet hey Shields as [__] yeah
he's has CT himself yeah he's he says
well [__] genius brain listeners let's
face it with copy starting at five
dollars in her bank account somehow
always depleting we are officially
entering a dupe session most products do
the same thing but are priced
differently solely based on the brand
name and that's where raycon comes in
because the wireless earbuds my friends
are not only a good duplicate but high
quality at the best price rate
constipation is to prove they shouldn't
have to pay an arm and a leg for Quality
sound and essential smart Tech listening
features you get a pair and a spare and
still pay less than you would with some
of these other more big name Tech Brands
out there I use it when I jog kickbox uh
cook just walk around the house listen
to great music you name it my friends
let me tell you something about some of
the features three customizable sound
profiles earbud tap functions noise
isolation awareness mode custom gel tips
for the perfect most comfortable in here
fit you have ever felt in your life and
what I personally like about it eight
hours of play time because when I'm on
the plane I need that extra play time go
to vibratecon.com brain today to get 50
off your raycon order that's by
raycon.com branding score 50 off
bywaycon.com
uh so if you guys don't know there's
also a guy named Joe Schilling and this
kind of works in tandem because Joe
Schilling was is an MMA fighter as well
yeah uh mainly known for kickboxing
um
uh he actually trains out and not said
yatang but uh the yard yeah uh oh [__]
in Lincoln Heights yeah okay so that's
Joe Schilling I've seen him multiple
times there yeah uh Joe's Shilling is
also kind of a meathead uh I think he's
retired now but he fought for Bellator
and he transitioned into MMA yeah I had
a pretty you know half and half Korean I
mean but his kickboxing career was great
yeah the guy's a [__] beast uh
Joe Schilling there's a video clip about
this guy who was drunk in a bar and he's
like dancing dancing Dr Dre right yeah
apparently he was like a huge [__] in
the bar people were irritated as [__]
with this guy right and Joe Schilling
being obviously a meathead himself which
like Joe Schilling is a meathead yeah
walking up and Joe Schilling on purpose
shoulder bumps the [__] out of him right
now that's arguable nobody can say if he
did it on purpose or not that's for us
to judge visually but being a human
being who has lived on this Earth I know
when somebody shoulder bumps the [__]
out of somebody just starts some [__] so
Joe Schilling shoulder bumps him and the
guy says some [__] to him albeit he was
very obnoxious Joe Schilling obviously
turns around and it looks like the dude
is like coming at him a little bit Yeah
and Joe Schilling knocks the living [__]
out of this guy that's [__]
entrapment man yeah
and the the drunk dude just fell into
his [__] spider web I feel like yeah
he fell right into it yeah and he got
cracked so [__] hard and you could
kind of tell that Joe Schilling wanted
that heat yeah he wanted to knock him
out because he was being obnoxious and
rude or whatever yeah right
um but according to Florida and you're
standing ground laws
um Joe Schillinger is not guilty of
anything that guy got [__] up he got
[__] up yeah got knocked out but he
was okay after right here
um but yeah he [__] him up and I guess
the guy has no grounds to like sue him
or pursue anything
or I guess because it was self-defense
because I guess you see in the video of
the guy raising is about to raise his
hands and just Joe Shillings that much
faster so but the thing about that is
it's like yo you didn't have to do that
it didn't have to go that way at all
because you were irritated at this guy
for being a jackass or an [__] you
didn't have to step in and knock his ass
out yeah you know what I mean like
that's the weird thing like you're a m
you're a trained [__] kickboxer a
champion kickboxer at that you don't
have that guy was a looks like a schlub
just like a regular Joe you know
obviously like why would you want to
like destroy somebody like that and I
heard like some other stuff people were
saying like oh I was there you know he
he was being rude to the waitresses and
those staff
you don't get to knock out somebody for
being a rude drunk you know at that
point then use your size to be like hey
cut it out yeah you know use a little
bit of your Authority don't set up the
trap to [__] knock his teeth out like
give him a warning like what does that
do like clearly this guy has anger
issues like Joe Schilling got some
[__] anger issues man like because I
you know we know people like who fight
and stuff like that and I've seen like
people who are training MMA they would
never do that they're just like God this
guy's being drunk and they're like who
cares but he took it upon himself to you
know teach this guy a lesson and for
[__] what like what was the point of
that [__] like you literally just beat
this guy down for just being a loud
drunk at a bar if if
Joe Schilling at any point in the video
said be careful I'll [__] you up because
I'm a trained fighter and he still came
at him and then he knocked him out then
I've been like
but this was just that's why I say
that's like just feels like entrapment
he's just like yeah I just feel like I
just wanted to Sock somebody which is
kind of like disappointing for somebody
who is who fights at at his pedigree
right it's very odd to see something
like that I don't know man some people
are just [__] nuts you know when
we're in K-Town we always see like some
of the craziest [__] that goes down oh
my God the people who are just looking
for trouble yeah that kind of [__]
that's why I don't ever go to Cape Town
though yeah but you know how many times
have we go like I've been to K-Town and
you're like you're like you'll walk by
like a long line and then somebody will
look to stare at you like they're
looking at you know you're looking at my
girl I was like how can I look at your
girl I'm just walking yeah like how was
that even possible why does that even go
through your mind yeah and they're just
looking to fight somebody all the
[__] time like maybe I'm not going
out out there at those times anymore but
I haven't seen those type of people
anymore like those kind of drunk Koreans
just [__] being belligerent and
trying to be a [__] hard I don't
think we go to those spots anymore right
calm doesn't exist anymore but we don't
go to those spots we go to a little more
adult spots where there's better food
better drinks more chill like when we
were going to like you know when we're
like I said Chapman Plaza and all that
other stuff there's always something
that's right because I went to Arena
last year I'm already old as [__] and I
went because somebody you know my friend
wanted to go
I went and my friend was DJing so I had
the invite and yeah I was so out of
place right and I'm sitting there like
you know just standing there with my
drink and then there's a booth right
there's a bunch of booths and this guy's
sitting on top of the seat and there's
just all these people around him and I
just see him starting to like Chuck his
shoulders oh [__]
tile puke right and it's boom all over
the table and everyone scatters like
[__] roaches when the light turns on
it was like
and he was like
and split it and it was coming up
it was like
coming out right and then it stopped
right and he was just sitting there
alone for a good minute or two because
he just couldn't believe what it just
happened and then he just got up and
left and then the other dudes at the
table were like which way where did it
go and then they [__] chased him like
they were gonna beat his ass
for throwing up why
they [__] chased his ass to [__]
kick his ass and I was like beat his ass
like bro he's already embarrassed yeah
he's that's why he's leaving yeah hey I
know you're embarrassed but get this ass
whooping too yeah dude
why he's gone yeah so I was like damn I
I don't want to be there and that
probably ties into like [__] beef
thick arena is featured yeah yeah yeah
that shit's hilarious there's some weird
like moments in K-Town just where I was
like what the [__] am I doing here man
like there's definitely moments where I
was in K10 I was like I hate this [__]
um I recently went to this event where
uh it was uh sponsored
by a soldier company right and let me
tell you some I was getting some K-Town
PTSD
it's the soldier going through your
brain yeah going passing through your
liver and you're like oh [__] yeah
flashback to 904. people just talking an
inch away from your [__] face drunk
as hell yeah everybody's Korean
you know
talking a big game
about who they are what they can do for
you yeah I'm a big fan of yours man you
know who I am I'll make a lot of money
I do import yeah export you know
whatever you need yeah
massage chair yeah it's like whatever
you need let's do it let's work let's
work you know I'm I'm obliging I'm like
yeah let's do it let's whatever it's
like so what do you want let's do this
business and I always end every sentence
like this I go before we even do work
let's see if we're gonna even meet it
for dinner hit me up yeah we'll go eat
and we'll chop it up then right so they
give me their number he goes hey this is
the guy you contact him you let him know
text him so I literally text him that
night I was like if you want to meet up
let's say eat guess what no response
back of course
of course what is that though I don't
[__] know it's like like then
obviously he can't get anything from you
yeah so he was just selling himself I
guess did he think that you're gonna be
like yeah yeah hey yo let's work yeah
yeah yeah I'm like all right cool hit me
up if you want the the offer's there you
know right if you want let's do
something I don't give a [__] you know
he goes I have a lot of money I was like
cool cool
unless that money's in my bank account
yeah I don't know if this is true or not
you might be a very important person
we [__] on so many people man but our
own people sometimes some weird [__]
dude you know like especially when you
see us at restaurants man I you know
when I eat in K-10 I see an older Boomer
Korean treating the staff like [__] yeah
oh I get ageism real quick
I don't I don't
there are certain things too like
I don't know what it is
um maybe it's because the Korean Church
experience was there was a lot of good
stuff but there was also some bad things
that I took away from it that I didn't
like you know we always talk about how
culture and a [__] church just
culture always beats out Church in the
Korean churches like it's always Korean
culture first and then church net
everybody goes to [__] Church really
only for business like it's just to make
connections yeah like that's literally
what it is it's a network for business
there's a church phone book right do you
have a church phone book yeah the
directory directory right and the back
side is everyone's business it's like
how everyone could like oh I need my car
fixed I need Teriyaki forgot about that
yeah you just reminded me of the
directory that was sometimes in yellow
green yeah different like construction
paper color holy [__] I just remember
that [__] yeah like and that's how
Koreans did business with other Koreans
you got to go to church and get the
[__] Church to write their phone book
that was just this weird feeling that I
would always get especially like
the idea that somebody expected me to
call them young and just because they're
older than us because and I'm like
listen dude I don't [__] know you
you're not my brother I wouldn't I would
never call anybody hung and the only
person I still call basically hung to
this day is my actual older brother yeah
I've never called my brother by his
actual name yeah I've only called him no
so with somebody I was like hey you call
me young and I'm like nah I I'm not that
[__] Korean you know do you know like
what I realized about myself
like I don't say young anymore
but then the people I do call Young is
because I'm scared of them
okay so that's like a deep-seated thing
from my past obviously right oh okay
well let's let's just put this in
perspective right have I called somebody
hung because they were an Affiliated
gang member and if I didn't they would
have killed me yes okay okay I'm saying
the average person yeah yeah all right
so let's oh but you don't do the thing
with crazy when's your birthday hold it
okay
no your name is [__] Peter Kim yeah
all right and your name is John Kim yeah
all right
and for some reason your name is Ezekiel
your parents can't even say your [__]
name
all biblical names and [__]
because we definitely need to talk
so we're not saying names here yeah
so we should throw these parties at our
at our apartment right
and there was this a group of people
that they used to they used to sponsor
me with a bunch of clothes but they were
you know local right yeah yeah I know
those Youngs and I remember one time
this they were just in [__] Ed's room
just smoking
like I just remember I couldn't say
anything yeah I remember like
so we were all drinking having a good
time right and I'm going into the
kitchen and into the kitchen is right as
room and I just see a bunch of guys in
there smoking in his room and I'm like
did he let you in there they're like
looking at your [__] books
she's smoking and [__] I'm like and I
wanted to say something but I thought I
was gonna die yeah but you can't like
yeah I know those Youngs like I can't
say nothing you can't say anything and
they actually end up smoking like uh a
gift of his that he got from his sister
which was these North Korean cigarettes
and they were not good and they just
jugged them
they're like dude these things are so
unfiltered I'm like yeah I remember
those because you showed me them I
thought oh this was really cool you
showed me all like the North Korean
paraphernalia that your sister got you
yeah and I see these fools [__]
smoking it but I didn't know it was I
was like is that that's like Dude these
cigarettes are so bad then you told me
it was your cigarettes I was like damn
I'm missing some cigarettes here let me
tell you something these dudes were and
it wasn't like a guess about like the
[__] that they would do right
like people know these people right and
they you know they told me like hey be
very careful about what you do and say
around these people long story short
with these people once again we're not
saying [__] names later on we found
out one of them died right yeah yeah
over some other crazy [__] and some
other violent stuff so there's a reason
why I call them come okay and I did it
because it I was scared and rightfully
[__] so yeah right so every time I
remember to the first you just [__]
brought this PTSD moment
so were they came to our place pretty
frequently right because you know they
were giving me free stuff or whatever
and honestly I couldn't say no I just
had to wear it yeah
everything you were on everything I was
on everything yeah I would have all your
posts every day every week so listen I
wore that [__] consistently and it was
like Illuminati kind of design [__] that
they saw everyone was like in the
comments like David's Illuminati yeah
every week yeah David's Illuminati oh
what's this full David about oh maybe he
is in some like gang [__] I'm like no no
I have to wear this guy is scared
here
people still don't do I was bitching
this to Cleveland was dying laughing
because he remembered the [__] he was he
goes that's why you were wearing that
[__] all the time I was like bro this
guy literally came up to me right and
we're still cool to this day he's very
[__] cool he's actually a very
different guy now um but who comes up to
me and he literally grabs the back of my
[__] neck like [__] like Habib to
a [__]
um uh the other the Russian dude right
the background behind that he goes
I'm hung right like grabs the back of my
[__] neck
and I'm fat too I made a [__] battle
Fat Sound you know I am yeah it's like
me hung right dog I [__] called that
full song from that point on yeah
what am I supposed to do right like
y'all getting Punk and these are the
type of dudes by the way none of them
say their actual real name they got
these [__] weird aliases yeah I don't
know one of those Young's real names
either
[Laughter]
to this day I don't know his real name I
got a I gotta like one of those
faux notifications like someone you
might know and was him because it was
the same thing to me
a real name yeah nobody I don't know I
don't think anybody [__] knows man
yeah those that's the type of PTSD that
I was getting from at that [__] Soju
event I'm like they're not all thugs
they're none of them none of them are
right but they are very it's very game
that they brings out of them that I'm
like yo it is so Korean Hollywood is
[Music]
dude I'll fly you out to [__] New
York hey get him a flight to New York
really
I had I had one of those yo we're gonna
yeah man we're gonna hang out with
Jessica you know I don't know what I'm
gonna do I was like who like Jessica
Hong Lee which one which Jessica he says
Alba foreign
[Laughter]
[Music]
and I'm listening to this for [__]
like 30 minutes right yeah I'm like yeah
cool let's do it honestly but first
before anything let's let's get a meal
first I'll text you after this and let's
get a meal of course and you know for me
because I'm a man of my word I just text
them hey man it was great meeting you
next week whenever you want to grab a
meal let's grab a meal no response back
course but what's gonna happen next time
I see them same [__] what happened man
I thought we were going to kick it it's
on you yeah
you know I thought we were gonna make a
bigger champagne oh man like maybe I
don't hang out the same norabang as you
bro
once again
I don't like liars yeah that's what I'm
gonna say I'm like hey bro I actually
hit you up
and by the way I've actually said this
before obviously in Jess and you're not
making things light but I was
you know you kind of get your point
across by making jokes right so people
laugh yeah and um it was for Kate who
the [__] was this company and it wasn't
a Soju company it was um
Supermarket a supermarket okay as a
supermarket very popular supermarket in
K-Town right but they wanted to do like
promotions with like YouTubers or
whatever right they were talking a big
game met up these dudes [__] I just
see smoking all this other [__] yeah you
know same thing
[Music]
I do everything I'm a number one guy oh
God you know what I mean just saying all
this other [__] yeah yeah okay fine
whatever
we reconnect hit them up
don't respond back at all right out of
[__] nowhere like a year later they
want to do like Instagram promo stuff
for the supermarket right they're like
hey what's your price I was like who's
this
and they go he's like you don't remember
like we had a good time we [__] know
about did all this other stuff I was
like yeah I hit you up they're like oh
did my guy not hit you up I was like
cool we'll work together but you got to
fire him yeah is he fired
he's laughing I was like I'm serious
yeah there's a guy right there's some
other Factor here
it's his fault I'll work with you if you
fire him he's like ah we can't fire up I
was like no I'm dead serious you need to
fire him it's me
you know what I mean just [__] around
but it's like I hate it like why are you
[__] with me dude then you wouldn't
believe it man like that kind of shit's
in Korean church too
like why do you gotta [__] play a big
game like it's Church yeah
yeah oh my gosh there's like
people who uh like these Elders in the
Korean community in the Northwest like
they all got together and they wanted to
put together a youth rally
right which is weird like you guys are
like in your 40s and 50s I don't know
why you guys want to put together a
youth rally
but they just wanted to put on this huge
worship event right so the idea is that
every youth group worship team plays two
songs each and they go up and then so
just the worship night right
and they wanted to host it at our church
because we have a really big you know
main sanctuary
and then so they all met in Tacoma and
said hey um this this challenge with
some other church I don't know God
my information and wanted me to come to
a dinner meeting with all these other
channel names like these Elders from
other churches who are putting together
Sven hosted at our church because they
want me to emcee it right so I was like
okay I'll go right and when I go to this
dinner they order food right so there's
just like old Korean men at a big tables
like 10 of them and I'm sitting in the
corner right but I barely have a seat I
barely have my own utensils I don't have
a cup of water right and they order all
this food
and they're passing around the chiggers
they didn't give me [__]
I didn't eat anything is aided for you
they just ate it all in front of me and
the weird thing was I was sitting to
next to the fattest [__] Korean I've
ever seen in my life this obese Korean
man who was China and then as he's
eating they're like talking in Korean
the whole time and then when it finally
gets to the matter of them seeing they
say oh this is you know Edward Park he's
going to MC and then that's
fat Elders eating and he looks amazing
[Music]
and like I didn't get any food and I'm
sitting there and it's like all right
you know thank you oh and then they all
left
and then the challenge that invited me
was like thank you Ed
I'm like I'm so hungry
[Laughter]
I was like dog like I was so much more
upset at the idea that these older
adjectives didn't even very unkorean
yeah it was so weird it was so [__]
weird the most Korean thing would be
like oh you haven't eaten like we should
feed you yeah what kind of unchrist-like
[__] you know I also don't like
about Korean people who do [__] like
that it's like bro you're a church
you're not a gang yeah like what are you
some [__] cotton pin [__] that's what
I'm saying they're Elders right that
means they were voted in Korean
Presbyterian churches then I got power
over so I'm you don't even know who I am
yeah but I'm supposed to automatically
bow down to them and be okay with not
eating dude I literally
I know like we talk a lot about some of
the bad stuff that happened there's a
lot of great stuff yeah right but these
this is the more interesting stories
I actually deleted the story from a
previous podcast because I actually said
this guy's name multiple times yeah I
was like okay I'm gonna take this out
but that was the other thing too like
Korean sometimes like fellowship and
brothership seems very gang culture like
right yeah like it's [__] like that like
that's him just trying to piss on you
and say like you should know who the
[__] I am yeah you are a church leader
you fat ugly [__] what are you doing
you're not that important why are you
even putting together this Youth Event
anyway yeah I don't understand why is he
belittling you right like that's the
thing too right there's a lot of like
Korean like older young [__] where they
treat it like gang [__] but it's like
yeah for me growing up like I grew up
around real gangsters like I knew
[__] thugs you know what I mean I was
never a thug but I knew some
[__] right so when I would go
to these churches and I see these people
try to do that to me act like what
you've seen before I was like dog you
don't understand what you're doing here
is laughable right literally I've told a
story where a guy put a gun to my my
dick because I made a joke yeah you know
what I mean you're over here like hey go
go pick up go pick up the trash hey get
the chairs
yeah I'll [__] slap the [__] out of
you because there's no consequences if I
do I'm not scared of you there's real
people I'm actually scared of that [__]
my life over you are not scary and
that's the phoniness that I [__] hate
to they just like they like belittling
you yeah they would do that a lot like
some of these older church people they
want you to know your place I'm here
you're here know your [__] place oh
you think you're cool because you do all
this video MC [__] I don't give a [__]
yeah
yeah I do it too so I grab a mic
you know knock knock joke
why chicken cross the road
you know what I mean and they only feel
good if you if you know your place yeah
you know and being spoken to like that
from those like from that part of that
Korean culture is something I [__]
hated so much but that's why I got
driven out the church because I was
fighting that [__] because the pastors I
was dealing with at the church I grew up
in like they were trying to make me do
free video [__] and I was fighting them
like no kind of thing and it's wrong
yeah and at the end of the day like it's
a lot I've told it before but like they
were conspiring against me you know to
withhold this money when there was money
set for me they wanted the organization
wanted to give it to me and then they
withheld it from me didn't want to give
it to me and then they put the blame on
me and they were saying that
like it was my fault and that it was my
attitude and my pride
using that word yeah right because they
were even you know what's worse you want
to hear this one they were like God told
me that you have to do this
that if you do this video he'll bless
you I'll be like dude that's crazy I
prayed yesterday yeah and God told me
that you got to suck my dick
God God told me if you suck my [__]
dick and literally thought that you were
gonna say something inspiring no I don't
know why
[Laughter]
[Music]
from the back I hate see like that's the
thing too don't weaponize [__]
Religion Don't weaponize God and use it
against me to get something out of me I
don't like that it's your pride you know
what it is
is your ego no call humble yourself no
they but they're but what they're really
saying not bow Before the Throne bow
before me
come you know you have to balance to my
authority I went to Seminary yeah I'm a
messenger of God yeah hey guess what you
know what's also a sin gluttony you
[__] Peggy seki how about that yeah
right
how about we start there yeah you know
what I'm saying like how are you going
to preach about everlasting life when
you might die when you're 50. you know
the only thing you were at Everlasting
was a Gobstopper you fat [__]
[__] you
oh PTSD I'm sorry people this is just
this is us no so like that's what this
feeling though right so like I said I
was gone for a while but earlier this
year I talked about my New Year's
resolution about going back to church
but now that I was in Washington like I
was just like one of the only church I
know there and there's my home Church
you know
um so I [__] went back to my own
church right
and the first week there
um after the service
the
um
there was this couple that I've known
since they were like in my college and
stuff you know and they were like two
separate kids I knew grew up and like
they married each other you know so we
went out to go eat pho afterwards and
they were telling me like they looked
over and they're like oh is that is that
Edward young and then but they looked at
me they said I was shaking really I was
shaking in my seat I was having like a
stress response yeah with me being in
that church in particular they said I
was shaking and like I was sweating you
know like oh my God
that's the Holy Spirit yeah
okay everything that kind of stuff but
for me it was like uh apparently yeah I
was having this stress response because
of how I was hurt yeah it was treated
there but then
for me
one of the biggest reasons why I went
back was exposure therapy because I had
to tell myself like
those pastors that hurt me aren't at
this church anymore
you know this is there's a new pastor
here
this is like it's been 12 years since it
happened it's different it's different
there's all these different people at
this church you know none of that so
there's some people there that
remembered you but yes yes yes but they
didn't know what happened because after
I didn't tell them what I just left just
bounced yeah in their eyes the way they
saw it was Ed left our church and moved
to LA yeah and you know his he did his
video career right yeah but in my shoes
was I lost my home Church the thing that
meant everything to me that even when I
started going to other churches in
Seattle I couldn't sit there either
because I would like have these yeah
stress responses and I couldn't sing
anymore I couldn't play the guitar
anymore I couldn't like sit in the seat
and listen to that because I would start
just
freaking like any anxiety attack or a
panic attack you know what yeah yeah so
then I became an alcoholic and I moved
to LA and I spent all these people in
L.A met me was I was fresh off the
church
hurt by this thing drinking like a
madman yeah yeah that's why if you look
back at me at that K-Town Ed it was a
lot the guy who was so such a regular I
could walk around with a bottle soldier
in my hand yeah and just drink it walk
around K-Town like that was me but that
was me
filling myself with all of that hurt and
pain yeah yeah that so going back to
church was mean like
working through it to be like this is
new this is different you know time has
passed because everyone else really did
move on with their lives because of
their perspective of how I live my life
time just passed they don't know
anything about that yeah meanwhile I'm
living this [__] for 12 [__] years
and he's like oh he just left yeah so I
had to bring myself to that reality to
be like
to be able to move forward while I was
there
it was a tough time because every
subsequent week was the same response
one kid after
he was like oh Edward what's up I said
are you mad like no why and he's like
your eyebrows are like full and I didn't
realize it yeah it was just I don't know
yeah I was walking around like that
but like I was there for like two months
you know so
the subsequent weeks that got better and
better exposing myself to that and I was
meeting with old friends who knew me
from back in the day yeah and I actually
told them what happened finally I told
them what actually happened to me
and they were yes like a bit shocked
and you know I just want to be real
you know
a lot of these Suburban churches don't
exactly know how to respond to these
things they said what did you do yeah
every single one of them
they were like what did you do and
that's the thing that drove me crazy
yeah because I asked myself that every
day for 12 years what did I do yeah and
so I asked them I don't know what did I
do yeah what was I like was I an [__]
did I do something to piss them off and
they're like no
like they never thought of it that way
right
and so I was also living the fact that
me telling them what actually happened
to me and the trauma
in a way but it didn't change anything
um
it was therapy giving away for me to let
kind of like truth yeah right but then
they were like well at the end of the
day what can they actually do nothing
yeah nothing Nothing's Gonna Change It
Happened 12 years ago like what could
they do hey oh it's your lucky day I
just invented a time machine yeah
it's not like that and so every time I
was meeting with these old friends and
telling them truth of what happened and
I felt nothing change afterwards it was
a reality check for me about like I said
before managing my expectations like
what did I think was gonna happen if I
told him the reality of this like I was
expecting me to feel better but I didn't
and that's when I had to look inside
myself like this is my problem yeah
because they didn't do it
you know so even if it was like talking
to the pastor the new pastor there uh
Pastor Jim Han uh it was a great guy a
great time meeting and sitting with him
and
nothing changed either like there wasn't
even no catharsis yeah it's like it's
like you're talking to him like an after
image yeah yeah like what's what's the
point so I had to live with that too
right like okay
it is all up to me yeah it's all in me
to have to deal with this old church
trauma you know and to be okay with not
being angry at what this is anymore
yeah and that's I think part of this
whole resolution of going back to church
and reconnecting to that
like I'll keep saying like it won't
change the way I actually think and
believe about what I do with a God in
general like I'll say I'm still agnostic
but then to be able to take in what
they're trying to say up there on the
pulpit without being like that's
[__] that's [__] hypocritical I
know none of your guys are gonna listen
to this [__] yeah and being a [__]
cynic like nobody likes that yeah you
know and just being like
hey hear it
and like receive what they're trying to
say you know the good word the good word
but it's because I'm you step out of
myself and be like you're a [__]
Debbie Downer
Why'd You Come why do you come if you're
going to be so sour right that's not why
you made this resolution you know I
found out because I went to church for
the first time because of pandemic yeah
a lot of time um he's never went we
never got back into it but Marion wants
to go back to church so I started we
went back for the first time last week
you know I found like I can't stand
church my [__] ADHD is nuts bro it's
crazy because I've never I think we're
talking we haven't done that in a while
right sit somewhere and like just focus
yeah holy [__] it's hard you know we're
doing we're friends you know this is
interesting stuff we get to catch up
with each other I could listen to
perfectly fine when I'm far away from
this person on the stage and he has a
story he's going into it next thing you
know I'm [__] shaking
my legs are shaking my [__] hands are
[__] itchy and [__] and was like wait
is this bad comedy
it's like that right I'm sitting here
just okay and I'm like okay you're
moving too much David you need to
[__] focus on something else so I
turn on my phone and I just start trying
to write what they're saying right and
then that goes into me somehow I'm in
Instagram
somehow I mean Instagram it's the pepper
the devil the [__] devil took a hold
of my thumbs and they opened up
Instagram and then I'm watching this
this kid called chromosome man
[__] save the day save the day by
exploding your building accidentally and
I'm giggling in the middle of a [__]
sermon and Mario's like what are you
laughing I was like that's a good joke
right
because I can't sit [__] still yeah
and it makes sense when I was a kid I
couldn't sit still either and I still
have it till this day I I bet you I
could listen better if I could just Pace
in the back
I hate so the church I'm attending in
L.A
every
like they have two services like a
different time like 10 a.m and noon or
something
and whichever one I go to I see this
girl in the back doing yoga throughout
the whole service
and just listening in doing their own
thing
and I actually really appreciated that
maybe that's her way she probably got
ADHD like a [__] yeah like I do
she's got a yoga mat in the back and
she's just stretching and and like
she's tuned in because if I listen to
his sermon online when I'm at home but
then I'm just pacing back and forth like
doing other things yeah I listen to the
whole sermon right right because my body
is moving but my mind is still but my
I'm focusing my attention onto what this
person's saying when I was there at
church I don't remember [__] yeah I
swear chromosome man yeah
that's it
that's all I remember
so so is it a public speaking problem in
the American church today then maybe I I
do they need to take do they need to go
to an open mic yeah to figure out how to
be more engaging and to work a crowd
maybe like listen like Erwin McManus is
a great speaker by the way yeah he's
awesome there's times where he speaks
where I'm like wrapped in yeah they even
got me back to tears a couple of times
but I haven't been in a sitting a
setting where I had to sit down and just
like sit there and pay attention it
would remind me of like school right all
over again and I just started getting
itchy I couldn't sit still and I'm just
like moving around and [__] but I don't
want to look like a crackhead I want I'm
representing Muriel too and I'm just
over here just itching like a
[__] and I'm like if I could
just get up and just start doing
cartwheels
I could listen to [__] everything
when I was streaming people really
understood they're like oh he really
does have ADHD you have to be doing so
much doing so I'm moving I'm talking
about 4 000 different subjects and you
can move on like that yeah and they're
like oh [__] he wasn't you're keeping up
with this wall of [__] comments yeah
you're a little like you're [__]
doing like I even I mean I'm watching in
these streams I'm like damn you're like
covering everything yeah like how are
you doing this I Don't Want to Miss a
Thing
like I told you I got ADHD like a
[__] dude it's insane and so I
think that was you know whoever came
onto those streams they understood the
most they're like oh he wasn't [__]
lying like this guy can talk about any
idea here idea here idea that's why it's
so hard for me to sleep yeah my mind
yeah it's it's just literally all these
synapses
well luckily like the at least the
church
um both in churches they've got you know
they they have a big projector screen
right and then some of the pastors I
that I can pay attention to is when they
have their notes and outlines put up on
the screen just bullet points exactly
what they're saying what they're talking
about at that moment right there
that is a great way to get people like
at least their eyeballs on something
like that yeah a lot like when they have
that thing like this is what we're
talking about and it pops up I'm like
cool now I know yeah now it's more like
a keynote and that's acceptable you know
a sermon can be in any presentation one
maybe passage should do more like
keynote presentations style sermons like
I remember how my mind drift is so hard
to the point where
because I'm doing a lot of gardening
stuff right and then like Robin was with
me and I forgot that I was supposed to
go to church and Mariel was a little
upset I was like oh that's what I
promised so I met up
I I took Robin to the church and then I
picked up because you know
he was high as [__] he went inside to
the church
and that's and then Robin just made this
joke he goes dude if [__] the pastor
talks about gardening he goes you got to
go to church forever right and lo and
behold [__] or wait Madness talks
about grapevines yo that's Jesus bro
that's the holy spirit amen kind of
freaked me out a little bit and I was
like what the [__] right but the problem
with me and my ADHD right he started
talking about grapevines right like how
God is like the source and then we're
the fruit we're the fruit We're The
Grapes we are you know we are the fruit
that he Bears right yeah you know so
we're the good deed the good word
whatever what not right but then my mind
starts going into this thing of like how
do I grow grapes what's the type of soil
that I need to grow grapes right what
does it say that in the Bible yeah I'm
like how would I trellis these things
right what part of my backyard could I
use to grow Grace does it get enough Sun
next thing you know the praise team
started the sermon was done wait what I
missed I missed how do I get to heaven
[Music]
laughs
20 minutes of that sermon I was in Napa
Valley right
and then he goes I just want you guys I
want all of us to Bow our heads and pray
I'm like [__]
wait the benediction
how do I escape here you know and I just
sat there and I could tell Mary was
looking at me like oh man he was really
into it yeah no I was thinking about
grapes
this whole time I was thinking about
grapes I catch myself with that too I'll
be like oh [__] what the [__] was he
saying yeah but you know what works for
me when I go back and listen to the
sermon on podcasts and I'm driving oh
then I'm all in dude that's so my mom
right she asked me she goes oh this was
actually recently she starts laughing
she goes you're in the car again and she
goes why do you only call me when you're
in the car and I was like because I
can't pay attention to you
there's something right it's a
multitasking thing right yeah she goes
oh
because that made because she goes when
you're on talk to me talking to me on
the phone at home it sounds like you
don't want to talk to me it's like it's
not that I don't want to talk to you I
can't focus yeah but when I'm in the car
like for some reason like my attention's
on the road which is automatic and then
you're the other thing that helps me
Focus driving yeah so I could talk to
you like because you're in Focus mode
yeah dog man that's the ADHD the
multitasking part of ADHD doing
something else helps me listen better
yeah yeah Mary doesn't get it she goes
why do you have Netflix on the
background how do you do that and edit a
video so did you doodle a lot in school
yes yeah
like I got in so much [__] trouble
for drawing in my notebooks because I'm
like you have no idea if I'm drawing I
am listening yeah but how how is that to
explain to your parents I got my [__]
ass beat like for all my drawings dude
can I tell you the story like real quick
I know this time this is I I would never
ever do this again when I look back at
this and I tell this story I'm very very
ashamed of this when I was at UC
Riverside
um uh there would be a certain I'm sorry
[__] lecture going on I can never pay
attention to what I would do is that I
would set up a camera and I would just
record it right with this little camera
thing and then you know for our friends
who had class we would switch people out
so we could just listen to the [__]
lecture later all right that's pretty
Smart Bro pretty [__] smart right so
only one of us would have to go yeah
holy [__] right and so one guy I don't
know why this guy did this [__] but I'm
recording this stuff and then in the
meantime I'm just listening to music
right
this guy comes up and he takes my earbud
out of my ear he was like hey that's
really loud
and then I looked at him and I just said
if you touch me I'll [__] kill you
yeah ever [__] touch me again just
tap like get your attention any other
way take touch your property that's way
past this is why I'm embarrassed right
yeah he does that [__] right and by the
way in order for him to do this he's not
sitting next to me he's
front of me so he goes turns around and
does that [__] yeah and so the whole
time you know what I do I'm such a
[__] [__] I get really close to
him and I just go
you start breathing into his [__] ear
through my nostrils oh God and I'm
making Clarity threaten him at this
point I'm making him super uncomfortable
he [__] gets up to a seat somewhere
else I move I go behind and I follow him
like a [__] psychopath yeah because I
hated how disrespectful he was to me
it's a little embarrassing I should
never do that [__] what I'm gonna do
[__] fight this guy in the middle of
a lecture are we doing you [__] idiot
but you're so petty you're making the
most a minor inconvenience the worst
inconvenience he's ever gonna experience
yes like that little thing he did to me
I wanted him to feel my [__] rage
dude it's a little embarrassing I will
never ever do that but you just spark
this [__] memory it was so annoying
the way that guy [__] did that [__]
and um another time too like I was
drawing doodling or some [__] and I just
hated when people would judge the [__]
that I did yeah right and I don't know
what the [__] it is about [__] white
people getting in your [__] business
and like I don't understand what the
[__] it is and you know not all white
people people right but this specific
thing it's an American thing it's an
American white American thing to impose
whatever the [__] you're doing or what
the [__] I'm doing right because like
they have some kind of authority okay
you're just some [__] citizen like I
am yeah shut the [__] up why the [__] do
you first of all the guy with the
earbuds things right yeah like okay
maybe you could hear a little background
noise from my earbuds whatever right you
can't get anything you could come up and
touch me like that it's entitlement it's
wild it's the wildest entitlement other
thing
doodling on my [__] right this girl
white girl next to me she goes like why
are you even here if you're not going to
pay attention
why the [__] do you care yeah why aren't
you paying attention to the lecture yeah
I was let me waste my tuition the way I
want to
seriousness
that [__] I've oh that was the weird I
never knew people who would get into
your business like that where I grew up
mind your [__] business that's all
that it is you mind your business you
don't get [__] up that's all that it
is so up Northwest we have Old Country
Buffet I think you guys have Country
Kitchen Buffet
yeah I never had that it's it's a it's
like this Buffet chain right we have a
HomeTown Buffet I think it's the same
chain okay delicious Fried Chicken
amazing yeah oh it's a fried chicken
story
so
yeah and this time we're poor as [__]
you know like um it's after the riots
and my parents lost everything you know
my mom works at a Korean market my dad
works at gas station
and whenever every time they'd save
money and once a month we'd go to the
buffet and feast on food we could never
have yeah it was the best the best and
we go ham because it's just like there
you know and then iron we're all eating
and there's old lady just just really
[__] old you know 80 plus old white
lady comes up and like
why don't you guys eat all the meat off
the bones before you go back and get
more
and then we were like like I think my
parents at first just did not understand
them and she was reiterating herself
thought to my parents
like you have to eat all the meat off
the bone then you can get more and then
yeah like that's where I remember my
parents were slowly starting to tick
after she left like processing it
processing it and when we were gone to
it they were [__] they stayed with
that [__] fuming fuming by the time you
left [__] because yeah that's what it's
like the uh like the bystander effect or
just like you're trying to rationalize
what's going on because it's so out of
place from what your normal life is like
you can't process it yeah it happens all
the time and I I know what that feels
like because there's sometimes too where
like you'll have these moments where
somebody will just do something so
disrespectful to you right and you just
take it then you're in the car and also
you're like
you just didn't know what was happening
yeah
nobody's there it could be a week later
you're in the shower and man
[__] I'm telling you you did
just think about it it's like have you
seen that Seinfeld episode with George
Costanza where George was eating shrimp
um at this meeting right
and then this guy's like George the
ocean called they're uh they're saying
to save some shrimp for later or for the
rest of us or something like that right
everybody's laughing and then he George
is in the car he goes well the dirt
store called and they're running out of
here
yeah but it's one of those moments
you're like what the [__] did this
person say like why do you think it's
okay for you to go ahead and tell me how
to live my life mind your own like it's
a [__] Buffet I never Buffet I'm
saying like that type of stuff that
would happen in college because I didn't
grow up around like white people yeah I
never experienced that stuff so that's
why to me it seems like a white American
thing you know I because I never
experienced it elsewhere Asian people
black people Mexican people never did
any of that [__] they're like that's
[__] weird and they just let you live
your life and do your own thing the idea
that you feel that you have to civilize
me is what it feels like you have to
teach me how to be a decent human being
a decent American yeah you know what the
America dude now I'm trying pictures of
you naked with weird titties
you got 96 areolas and the rest is
titties
and you can't do nothing about it what
you gonna do about it you're gonna tell
on me I'll just say it's [__]
abstract art what are you talking about
I thought this was a liberal College
yeah [__] out of here dude oh you just
brought those two memories back to my
[__] head dude embarrassing on the
first one I shouldn't I was a little
aggressive but that [__] one right
there dude telling me that I should be
paying attention basically saying that
I'm wasting my car who cares [__] yeah
who the [__] cares let me do it my way
it doesn't take away from you I'm not
disturbing the class I'm sitting here
drawing this rooster on top of this
[__] Barn let me draw it dude
at my gas station
you know someone had changed I pulled up
once right it was like three ones or
four ones and I handed it to him right
and apparently they were upside down one
was and he says you know when you go to
7-Eleven they're all facing up on the
same side
I was go to 7-Eleven then yeah what the
[__] why tell me this dude you just got
four dollars I don't know what you want
from me you know
yeah I told him I got him I taught him
how to be a very better American so like
I was driving around town too this is
back up there too
and I was on my way to the weed store
right
and
apparently I was going faster than like
35 right and
the thing was this guy
follows me to the weed store right
and then he goes hey that was a school
zone the speed limit is 20 right but
here's the thing it's like not school
you know when it's a school time when it
flashes yeah right now yeah but I didn't
even say that I was like so shocked
because he followed me first and then he
just came to my window so I rolled it
down
and then he says
you know if the cops were there and I
found you they would have took you out
of your car and beat your ass
and I'm like this is like literally
you know already at time when like
police brutality is already hot yeah and
in my head I didn't even process it I
just he just went back to his car and
left
and I went into the weed store and I was
like wait a minute yeah what the [__]
why do you have to threaten me like that
yeah right for speeding the cops should
beat my ass in a time like this yeah and
I'm already thinking about this getting
enraged and then I complained to the
[__] wheat store manager like and
then afterwards like what the [__] is he
gonna do he's like bro hi yeah he's like
oh I'm sorry bro I'm really sorry that
happened yeah it's like uh to be honest
with you man I don't even know where the
[__] I'm at it's like don't you work
here no uh I can help you bro
it's like you just sit with that it's
just like you you live with this [__]
like why why do they have to [__]
like say like that to me right so
here's what I realized then I do that
too
do the white people like the customers
who give me [__] and I start acting like
an authority over them about their
behavior and how they're acting and then
I talk to them like an adult and [__]
and oh my God they [__] hate it yeah
they [__] hate it like when I give
them a reality check for their [__]
then they start going off like their
children yeah and then you start then
that's when the yukook kind of chicks
[__] because they run out of [__] to say
I got nothing they got but except call
me a goog and then
all of it when I'm trying to like I said
I do my thing and try to look at [__] 35
000 feet in the air and look at two
human beings like a man this doesn't
feel like this man because of his race
should not speak to him that way and it
could not it might not be anything about
race but the fact that he just doesn't
want somebody to speak to him that way
because his culture
is
it's a lot of entitlement it's
entitlement to be able to just tell
other people the way it is because in
their country that's what it feels like
like oh you let me show let me educate
you how things are here yeah and no you
don't do that to me you're in my country
yeah and I'm like but you're behaving
like a jackass yeah I didn't know that
was an American thing it's my first you
know Amendment right and okay all right
okay I'm not allowed to have a First
Amendment right you know yeah like I'm
I'm not allowed to express myself the
way I am with my culture I have to be
like you you know that's why you just
[__] put your hand on your shoulder
and you say I'll pray for you that
you're gonna go to hell yeah
you [__] piece of [__] like what can
you do to these people like is it our
job to even educate them when they're
trying to educate us it's just exhaust
cyclical it's just like weird just to
see that happen you know and I'm like oh
is this this is like some weird like
this is probably what we would call
weird white American stuff right like I
said not like a majority of people that
I need a lot like this that's why white
people adopted woke because they realize
these things too right yeah you know
it's just like some weird [__] that I
see you know I don't know why in their
mind they thought because in their mind
it's Justice they're doing the right
thing
you know they're the hero in their store
the jackass yeah you know so what the
the story that they're writing in their
head they're like there's ching chong
don't speak English yes I'm gonna be the
good American and show them the way yeah
so like as like because I imagine like
this girl right this [__] hairy
armpit [__] [__] stank ass [__]
dirty blonde-haired [__] mother I
still remember her face yeah like her
just coming up to me going like okay
see this is what I'm gonna do
I'm gonna teach this slant-eyed [__] how
they should he can assimilate better
don't waste our tax dollars and
education on doodling on paper
and now she said that there's a [__]
fireworks behind her yeah
and then a [__] congratulations I did
it American flag behind her right
and then she doesn't even [__] know
that I slashed their tires which is
crazy
idiot oh my gosh anyways guys uh that
wraps up this episode of The Genius
brain podcast uh you could catch at
edparkvp uh Bible study at Momos is his
podcast yeah yep uh uh Momo's or Momo
Momo Momo not plural uh genius brain
every Sundays at 12 p.m secret society
is the clothing rat check it out
s-c-r-t-s-o-c-i-e-t-y.com check it out
fashion Basics high quality [__] [__]
uh put a lot of heart and effort into it
this is our fifth year going on strong
uh thank you for the support and love
and we'll see y'all next time peace
peace